if you've been watching us for a while
you know we love surf shock why do we
love surf shot because surf shot is very
good say it again surf shark why is it
good brian well it's a virtual private
network that allows you to be anywhere
in the world virtually it also allows
you to browse the internet anonymously
for some of you out there buying things
you don't really want people to know
about do you know what i mean stuff that
you won't want your neighbors opening so
surf shark allows you to bypass geo
blockers that means when you see a clip
on twitter and it says not available in
your area
you can go aha
gotcha i'm anonymous i can be anywhere
even in your bedroom
[Music]
the newest feature at the surf shop is
the surf shot antivirus which gives you
security and it lets you have that peace
of mind when you're online big addition
and not only that you also get advanced
malware protection
malware it's basically viruses and [__]
a few hundred and unlike a lot of the
competitors one account with surfshot
gets you cover across unlimited devices
that you own so all that is included
when you sign up using the code jody you
get three months extra for free and you
get 83
off what a deal so with that said enjoy
the video
[Music]
at one time i was homeless instead of
going home every night there was no home
to go to
life at home was very difficult i grew
up being abused
i lost my belt i lost respect i
embarrassed my family my vision was
pretty much non-existent i was able to
just about scrape by the medicals
i come out i have supreme confidence i'm
scared to death
i'm afraid of everything
i didn't care about living i just wanted
to die i got up and i felt the weight of
the world was lifted off my shoulders i
knew i was going to make a comeback
fighting this was designed for me to and
what makes us who we are
i'm so far ahead of this game
my dream my vision for myself is to be
the greatest martial artist to ever live
i have always been a fighter there's
nothing i do better in this life than
fighting
there ain't never been a month like that
to me i was born to do this
nobody can get close i'm the best
fighter in the world i'm the most brutal
and efficient and more ruthless
welcome back to the pain game podcast
today's guest is one of my favorite
youtubers one of yours probably if you
are into combat sports youtube boxing
all of that it's the weird concept
what's up man
i am i am
very excited to be here very honored to
be here uh one thing before we do
anything
i've been waiting so long to say uh just
a couple things to you personally and
one of those being
i hope people realize you're the og in
this scene and without true jordy
without your entire team you and liz
there is no wade concept so i just i
wanted to give you those flowers man
you're the goat in this thing no i
appreciated me and i think you've done a
great job i was frustrated when i came
into youtube after a few years thinking
like where's this new blood where i
thought there'd be more you know i mean
i thought we would sort of and here you
are me you're a [__] legend of what
you've done and there's a good reason
why
people are
appreciating you is because you know
boxing but you understand youtube and
like me you've got a passion for both so
yeah let's um
let's kick it off
with jake paul
oh yeah fury
um
they've made it official today thank god
yeah big john
after the logan paul podcast
uh where we talked about you know this
being
negotiating and uh it looks like tommy
versus jake's gonna happen and i think i
might have been the one who mentioned
big john actually um
big john uh does a video right
afterwards and says this people's
mentioning me saying i'm uh saying that
there's uh
negotiations in place for tommy to fight
this clown from overseas it's not true
i'm having nothing to do with this at
all because it's a pile of [__]
you know i don't like
anybody
what's associated to those people over
there
they're nothing but a pack of tosses
youtubers and i'm not interested in it
one bit in any way shape or form so
people hear this don't keep using my
name saying i'm saying this and i'm
saying that it's not true i want nothing
to do with this fast at all not now not
ever
have a pleasant evening
the pleasant evening the pleasant
evening is beautiful by the way
right at the end have a pleasant nothing
but a pack of totters
i'm like well you've just called us a
tosser but i'll try and have a pleasant
evening
um i had no abs any knowledge at all of
john um for sure being involved in any
negotiations at all right i heard it
mentioned on talk sport which is a
sports show in the uk
and i was like oh cool like you know you
hear something and you just relay it to
someone else like i heard this
yeah and like and then
john reacts the way john does he will
just get the next clip up which was just
to be clear
24 hours later
just just
just a day later jake paul team
and about this fight
listen mate will you want this fight
with you there's one problem
we can't travel
tommy hasn't got a team
his team members are not allowed in them
i thought there was no negotiations john
yeah i thought we were not interested
some tossers madison square garden made
ain't accessible for us is it and you
know that it's not wheelchair accessible
uh they've
got a disabled fella who they wanted to
bring it's not gonna work for us what
we'll do
will take less money and we'll fight you
anywhere else in the world
yeah because we can't travel and tommy
he's not going to start getting new
teams in four weeks and getting
different things and all the strange
people involved because that don't work
yeah these strangers showed up
i'd say not the strangers come on now
there is guidance especially and you're
talking to me now because i'm in charge
me of tommy's career well a day ago you
told us it wasn't [__] happening so i
don't know who's told you you're in
charge but i just don't trust you though
i'm sorry john i'm sorry he's coming bro
he's coming for you i was a total
yesterday god knows what i'm going to be
he's probably going to say how did i say
i'm
tomorrow he's just changed his soap it's
like the weather and he
oh good oh [__] me i hope he doesn't hit
me to be honest we are
at this moment in time the sixth of
august is being very poorly promoted
mate isn't it it's shocking and i think
there's better a better job could be
done of it to be fair will you it's all
rush rush rush
i don't actually disagree with him on
that one thing i don't
i don't either though yeah that's the
thing is tommy and john have been silent
the whole time yeah bad promotion yeah
it's been both ways you just two not
even a day ago said that you weren't
going to negotiate with these tossers
and then
you come out and go well this
promotion's been terrible
you got me like
i think the whole idea was an
announcement to be made and john took it
upon himself to sort of
put you know what i mean the cop before
the horse stays like well that's that's
been the story of john this entire uh
build up here i wake up this morning to
another text to my manager saying that
tommy fury is pulling out of the fight
we agreed to all of the terms everything
is ready to go we're 45 days away from
the fight we agreed to his 2 million
dollar purse we agreed to vote by the
way
crazy
crazy money a lot of testing extra
flights extra rooms extra tickets to the
fight we're scheduled to have a press
conference next week in new york his
whole entire team was like yeah
everything's good we're signing the
contract today today it kept on getting
pushed it kept on getting pushed till
now what's the excuse
oh i can't come and i can't do it
because my dad can't be there with me
during not a good look that is that is
it's really yeah
tommy your dad has been banned from the
united states for 15 years you've known
this the whole entire time he's a
criminal he's not allowed in
when he fought he is a criminal party
i love the way he just rolls out there
he's just a criminal he's not allowed in
anthony taylor in cleveland neither
tyson nor your dad were there with you
in your us debut [__]
back
now all of a sudden you need your team
with you that doesn't make any [__]
sense i will agree to not have my team
around me during the fight week i will
agree
to not fight with my coaches in my
corner we can both fight solo dolo like
i know jake's polarizing and i know
people don't like him bro but after that
i think and i've seen you were pretty
much the same like it was the comments
on all of the boxing channels that
uploaded that that those same channels
like ifl that normally you'd see the
comments just trashing jay it was a
unanimous flawless victory 10-7
like everyone was like
tommy fury needs to sign this [__]
deal now because if not he is being
punked by
that youtube kid who nobody respects and
if if your legacy is pulling out of a
jake paul fight twice you might as well
go home
yeah this is not for you if that's if
that's the way it goes for tommy it's
just it's not for him but luckily like
you know tommy
it's been it's been so weird you you
told me you know you're like hey let's
do the pain game and
you said let's talk about this jake paul
thing and you put the john fury show
right and that's what this has become
the john fury show yeah and to a degree
that's like it's not even involving
tommy like tommy is having to fight and
claw and scratch for his own breath like
he's not even a part of this at this
point it's jake and john and it's like
john might as well lace the gloves up
and get in there himself at this stage
because he's become so integral and i do
think that his involvement with tyson's
career remember when tyson had his uncle
training him and then
he went to obviously ben and then now uh
to cronk
it's surprising that they haven't done
the same with tommy i do think john is
struggling to let go of his son and let
him fly
and when you've got john doing a story
that day is saying i'm in charge
and then later that day jake paul punks
tommy out and makes him look
a
you know bad real bad yeah it wasn't
good no no yeah and and then tommy
immediately on social media goes i'm
taking the [__] fight
yeah he's not listening to john
i know it does feel like there's two
versions of reality in that family
there's the there's what's happening
where
john wants tyson in you know malcolm and
he doesn't want him out in vegas and he
wants to train tommy and and then
there's what's really happening
and
you did see a little bit of that when
jake was mouthing off to
john in the press conference
and how the two boys were sort of
giggling like dad you know was he yeah
there's the old man yeah like
so yeah i think we're kind of all
getting into some weird family dynamic
here where that's partly of the issue
yeah yeah i think that john is is in his
own head a bigger part of this than he
really is right and and this is what you
talked about with tyson you know even
when back when john was was talking
about how they weren't going to
negotiate with with deontay wilder and
they weren't going to take that fight
because tyson wasn't ready and then
tyson and frank and bob were like yeah
no we're going to do that
yeah
yeah sure for john it feels like a lot
of the same stuff is happening to him
again and i think because maybe tommy is
his last kind of project right because
tyson got away from him got to like you
said went with ben then went with sugar
hill and took it to the next level
tommy should be doing the same i said in
my video tommy needs to get away from
john
especially in in the decision-making
department it's it's not a good thing to
have john popping off and making you and
your legacy look bad by going i'm in
charge of this like
yeah i didn't have to come out and be
like no no no
it's tricky for john because i get
you're trying to protect your son and i
actually respect that and i'm sure that
to the best of his ability that's what
he thinks he's doing here and like i've
seen him break things down before and
predict things i'm like all right you
are you're a smart boxing brain there's
no doubt about that it's everything else
i i get why honestly it's his pride yeah
when he talks about the fury family i
get from those gypsy roots like
if you've watched any of those sort of
bare knuckle documentaries
it isn't about the favorite sun as it is
about their last name
um i remember people like the joyces and
all of that you've seen them like
they're iconic but like at the same time
like the rest of the world the boxing
world we don't care about the furies as
john calls them we care about tyson fury
and i do think john's smart enough to
kind of know in reality
none of the rest no one cares but he's
clinging on as best as he can to sort of
build this sort of thing in his head of
like
my son is the the best fighter who ever
lived and now yeah my other son and this
on the other side i feel like he is dug
tommy and to a place and put him and
listen jake is a great narrative spinner
he's one of the best at doing it and he
even
put out a video just a couple minutes
ago talking about how this is the
greatest challenge of his life he's
fighting a fury he's not talking about
tommy specifically but he's using that
invoking that last name because john has
done this and put this pressure on tommy
and said the furies are fighting men
we're not you know no one can beat us
and i think that that pressure is
actually creating a bit of a problem
the injury in camp was partly down to
that pressure we've seen tyson hammering
him in the ribs with that medicine ball
absolutely
not necessary by the way just not
necessary
and i think the pressure can make you do
things like that in camp where you're so
worried about losing that you over train
and push it to the limit and then this
potential pull out again
if whatever john says about jake paul
there's respect there that he is a
threat to his son because you wouldn't
be considering not making a fight happen
twice if you had no respect for him
yeah and that's that's that's the the
part that no one's really saying and
he's saying it without saying the words
is that there's something there right he
does see something in jake where he's
like
let's try to play some mind games back
here let's try to like hold this thing
off as much as possible get him
uncomfortable because we're not as
comfortable as we're saying
going into this thing that tommy's just
going to walk through it and tommy's
going to be in that press conference
without his dad
it's going to be interesting
yeah that one that one's one i said in
my video i'm so interested to see how
tommy acts without john there right as
that filter because john can kind of be
the wild kind of
say whatever that i mean he told jake
that tommy was going to bend his girl
over so it's like he's not going to be
there doing that do it like a dog do it
like a dog
so it's not going to be that so i want
to see how tommy because jake's going to
be goofy he's going to say you know
goofy stuff he's going to try to get
under tommy's skin but
like you talked about this is the best
fight you can make right now in the
youtube scene like skill for skill
like you said pro boxing youtube boxing
this blend of things that we just
haven't seen yet and i think a lot of
people are still on that side of pure
boxer youtuber and we haven't really
moved off those lines so we're finally
gonna get some clarity there which i i'm
so excited for but the problem i've got
is when everyone starts saying jake paul
isn't a boxer and tommy is and then i
look at the level of opponent tommy's
fault
there's not i think like one or two
fights at most for tommy where someone's
really come to win
yeah i'm thinking of that ginger kid um
who was who gave him a good goal jeremy
great kid yeah yeah yeah he was solid
but like
he came after tommy toon he put tommy on
the back foot
i think he was lacking the confidence a
little bit to really believe he could
win but he went after him a bit and i
think that that's one of the issues i
see coming into this fight is
jake paul
whether or not it was reality every
fight he had felt like a step up and
every fel fight felt like an added sense
of risk there
and especially with woodley he had a
legit test in front of him where it was
difficult and i don't think tommy has
had anyone in there with him where there
that was that element of doubt of i
might not have enough for this guy
if you're in that situation for the very
first time and you're main eventing msg
and you're in there with a kid who
is so used to being the center of
attention not even talking about the
skill but it could have that mcgregor
effect that we used to see mcgregor
where when he would fight a guy who was
not used to the level of press it wasn't
used to being main event and all the
added pressure we might say even if
tommy is a better boxer
we might seem crumble and jake has
thrived in these he's main invented two
cards now back to back right well i
guess he's main event more than that but
in a big stadium with people main
evented and now it's going to be tommy's
first time in msg in front of all these
people no like he said no team there
this is
jake paul a guy that just picked at you
for the last year i don't know how
mentally he goes into that having never
done it having never fought for this
amount of time in his life
and just in that big scene what happens
to him mentally i don't know i'm not
saying that he can't do it i i think
anybody if you just take a look at it go
okay it's a fight and you can convince
yourself to block things out then it is
just a fight right and i don't put too
much into it but when it's your first
time
it's in one it's the mecca of boxing
you're going in there against a guy that
you've talked so much about being just a
youtuber and having nothing for you and
that hitting the pads with your dad is
harder it's going to be a it's going to
be a real awakening to see that crowd
for him and i i that's the biggest issue
if you're a tommy fury family one
mentally i 100 give the edge to jake
paul in terms of uh him being at home in
that arena right yeah and also
the chips have been down and and make no
mistake that last fight i did not think
he looked good but he dug deep and he
pulled that knockout out the bag
so even when he hasn't performed well he
slept the guy who's really
you know we all thought he didn't have
the right to be in there with you know
so normally if i watch a guy fight and
then i watch another guy fight i can
sort of visualize how this is going to
look but i am struggling a bit with that
because their competition is so hard to
grade that jake's for an athlete and
nate robinson yes he fought an
overweight fat wrestler in ben and then
finally woodley who
woodley didn't look like a good boxer
but is a tough guy i guess what people
want to know is can jake fight a boxer
and when they ask that question what
they mean is can jake fight someone that
moves like a boxer that has experience
in a boxing ring that throws like a
boxer it defends like a boxer that's
gonna
turn up volume that's going to be able
to throw more than one punch at a time
and then follow up
and tommy does answer some of those
questions right what i think jake
doesn't want to necessarily get into
even though i've heard and i've talked
with bj about them throwing 80 to 100
punches around
uh where was that in the last fight you
know because this is the thing exactly
the bj flores thing for for a good while
i was like this guy he's he's good
talker i'm seeing the improvements in
every fight from jake
and then we had the woodley fight and
i felt like jake fought with more fear
in the woodley fights than i'd seen from
him like
his his inability to fight in range
and when when woodley entered that range
instead of popping that jab out
he really reverted to tucking his chin
down and throwing those big overhands
and and a lot of clinching just not able
to control the fight with this jab
it was
a step backwards
not just a little one actually it felt
like
that last fight it was
god awful if i'm being brutally honest
it was [__] terrible
and that knockout saved it and for me i
think
if bj flores wants to keep his job we
need to see
a big step in the right direction in
this fight because if he fights like he
fought against woodley aside from that
knockout punch there was nothing there
that was on the level of what i've seen
from tommy
yeah no listen if but in previous fights
like the gib fight i'd seen
a lot of good signs you know what i mean
uh but
i don't know what it was about the
woodley fight but he just in either of
them he did not look composed when you
talk about tyron woodley and the
differences you saw with him even in the
first to second fight
the danger that that's present when
tyron woodley's in front of you is
completely different than a guy like
gibb right so where gibb could come
forward and did hit jake with a big left
hook and it didn't really faze him right
he didn't fear that power yeah uh tyron
woodley a different story obviously when
you've been hit by it and you get put
through the ropes in that second fight
you know there's a present danger right
and
you know not making excuses for jake but
he did take it on 12 days but the
problem is tommy is a volume striker and
jake hasn't seen a volume striker that
can put him on his heels yet yes gibb
tried but he didn't respect kid right
there was no respect there
tommy's gonna try to he's gonna try to
come forward and throw combination
punching at jake now what you said makes
a lot of sense can jake establish the
jab early
if not and tommy's able to get jake
clinching continuously
over and over and if jake listen jake
has great timing so if tommy does come
in a little out of control over shoots
the big right hand we've seen it it's
there
it's one of the tommy's biggest
weaknesses
this possibly works in jake's favor the
fact that because woodley was biting on
fans left right and center so he wasn't
he wasn't there a lot of the time
whereas tommy is going to be more
comfortable more confident and more like
a boxer so he's not going to be out of
range anywhere near as much so
it could set the right hand up nicely as
as we've seen with tommy does get caught
by that right hand it's just like
anthony joshua found out against usic if
you allow the boxer to steal three
rounds early and start racking them up
you're then chasing and then it becomes
a whole different kind of i don't
and not to say that jake can but i
you don't want to go volume for volume
with tommy in my opinion and if he does
get down early say tommy steals two
quick ones
fighting him from behind is going to eat
at that gas tank tommy can tommy's got a
great jab too like jake's got a good jab
tommy's got a great jab so tommy can
coast behind that jab if he needs to
right so it's
a manager fight well like like
absolutely i will give him that like in
in the fights i've seen him in like but
if i'm if i'm tommy's camp that that
power difference between him and jake is
on my mind because you can honestly say
jake's a cruiser he can crack and that's
something tommy hasn't seen yet yeah
respected so they're both gonna say
things that they've not seen yet and
that's where the excitement comes into
for us as fans because we don't know how
they're going to react we don't know how
jake is going to be composed when he's
got a guy popping that jab and
controlling the ring and having that iq
but we also don't know if tommy can dig
deep when he takes a big shot
and and and control himself and get
himself out of danger and we don't know
what his chin's like you know what we do
know is tommy does not have a lot of
power like we just know that now there's
there's so many rounds where he should
have gotten kids out of there as
and then after that last fight when he
walks into the locker room and tyson's
like well you nearly got him out like
[__] hell it's not what you want to
hear from big bro like world champion
you know it's gonna have to be jake
getting out to a good start the last
couple of fights jake has been a slow
starter
he's gonna have to get out to a quicker
start he's mentioning his legs feeling
like jelly and not feeling and that's
another thing too jake's been in this
now this is twice his main event he
should know how this feels and
we shouldn't just look at tommy and be
like is the moment big for tommy jake
has even admitted that the moment has
has maybe gotten to him a little bit in
these last two and then he settles in
and he has a good fight
uh especially the tyrann one fight i
thought he had a way better showing but
he has to get out to a bit a much faster
start because tommy will the bell will
ring and tommy will meet him and he'll
start working the jab
like immediately it's like clockwork for
those guys and this is why we talk about
a boxer yeah i i think jake has to
roughhouse this guy i think yeah i think
ironically there's been a lot of talk
about uh aj doing the similar thing like
it's it is it is it's power versus
boxing isn't it you know what i mean
like he's got a rough house him we've
seen when tommy has struggled it people
they've just not followed in after after
they've hurt him a little bit
um i think he's been let off but when i
look at his performances against um was
it anthony taylor who we fought in
cleveland
finally anthony taylor in cleveland yeah
that
didn't look great like i mean anthony
taylor was a tricky it was definitely a
tricky fight for him for whatever reason
i think like you we've been talking
about part of it was he was in complete
new territory versus a guy he really
didn't know what he was getting into
and secondly when the fight started he
just it looked like he wanted to be
pretty much anywhere else he just could
not get any type of momentum going it
looked like he didn't really even try to
it was like he was just kind of there
and okay i'll work my jab and i'll throw
a couple of these and then after he got
hit with a couple right hands he's like
you know what let me just coast this jab
to the victory i just feel like jake
hits so much harder than tommy correct
when that first punch lands
properly we're gonna get such a good
reading from tommy about how he feels
about that let's talk about logan
obviously we had him on the podcast he
mentioned he wants to fight dylan dannis
we don't know if that's uh mma or boxing
i imagine it's boxing
yeah
dylan uh dylan dylan got a bit i mean
naturally
yeah he tweeted something which is
pretty much all he's done in the last
three [__] years and he also said
that he wanted to fight me which i
thought was [__] hilarious you've
been boxing though bro i'm just a
politician
albeit a podcaster who would beat the
[__] out of dylan dennis
i am not actually a fighter though like
in my head i'm like bro like
use you you've got a fine uh amount of
time that people are going to give a
[__] what he's got to say
right and when he's pinpointing his uh
little tweet at me i'm like bro you're
wasting your five minutes here like
fixate that on logan and and and
manage your career in a way that's less
uh of an imbecile than what you've been
behaving like this guy is all of the the
credit he once had for being the
up-and-coming
student it's straight blast jam and the
jiu jitsu wizard and you know a real one
to watch
that's just died to death and watching
him get choked out by a [__]
chocolatier part-time bouncer i'm like
bro you you know coming after podcasters
you've got you've got big problems with
your
i'm doing good in my career you're not
doing much like come on as far as the
the the fight between him and logan goes
you know
i really don't know what to say about it
um have you always dylan hit pads or
anything like that yeah i've seen i mean
we we've obviously all seen dylan uh in
his two fights at bellator i've seen him
on the bag i've seen him doing you know
little bits and pieces he'll put out on
instagram um
definitely i'd say very poor hands out
this kid like he's not do you know how
some people like ben askren for example
they're not they're great grapplers not
punchers
he's so funny there's just i said my
video i said this in my video i ended up
not putting it in but i was like you
know he looks like a younger basket a
little bit but
but yeah he really does move like when i
watch him punch i'm like there's just
like
there's nothing there there's just no
snap there's no power like yeah
he's in trouble in his career generally
because the minute he struggles to get
someone to a to the ground
he's i mean even even when he's on the
ground as we see him with the
chocolatier but like
you you know this no wonder he's sort of
tweeting from the comfort of his own
home because he knows like
the minute
he goes out there and gets exposed for
lacking in a massive
quality that you need in fighting
all of this dylan danis being a thing is
is over immediately
yeah
i think
if logan does go through with that fight
and they've been talking about it for
years and dylan you know seems talks
like he wants that fight
um
i mean obviously i favor logan logan's
been doing this uh logan's a a really
really high
level athlete outside of boxing in my
opinion i think he could have done a lot
of different things
uh so when he got into boxing
supernatural ability um
i think he is just a guy that picks up
the sport really quickly and dylan just
i don't know what's you know what
honestly you know what i think what's
going on with dylan is i don't think
that knee surgery has been
fully rehabbed to the point where he is
confident in doing anything yet um
people forget and this is not like a oh
like let's feel sorry for dylan but he
had a full like reconstruction lcl acl
completely blown out in 2020 right and i
feel like it has taken him a lot longer
to get back than he realizes
when you see him he looks like a puffy
overweight
like welterweight now he he he doesn't
look in shape and that's obviously down
there you're injured you can't do the
cardio
he's talked about how he eats like trash
too he's not he's not ever like he's
talked about it in videos he's not a
like super healthy dieter either but
i think that's a big reason that he's
not saying it but i think that knee
rehab has not gone as well as he wants
and it's an acl at the end of the day
you know he hasn't fought in three
[__] years mate i know like i know i
can't like he doesn't realize how lucky
he is that p people like logan even
mention his name like
you fought a couple of bums three years
ago you used to spar conor mcgregor and
this is the thing like i know i made a
joke earlier on that but like i don't
give a [__] about this guy like i don't
hate him i don't i don't dislike i'm
just i laughed when i seen him say that
like it's nothing right but in my head
i'm like bro you've got
yo yo your window is closing and
three years without a fight like
i don't give a [__] what injury what
surgery you've had this should be sorted
by now you've got
like your body is probably giving up on
you if this if you're still unable to
get in a competitive ring or cage at
this point like what are you doing and
he's becoming that guy who
talks about fighting but never actually
achieves anything he's he's in danger of
not being a husband he's in danger of
being a never was because
like even jake shields replies to his
tweet underneath after he's tweeted
about me going i guess you won't sign
the contract if i hear me either will
you because jake shield's supposed to
have a fight i'm like bro you're talking
about me you've got pro fighters who
want to have a thing with you this is
never going to happen bro i'm like yeah
you know what the [__] you're doing with
your brain
say what you will dylan is is very good
at using his social media presence
whatever that may be whatever it is it's
not obviously as big as as some people's
is but he's good at using it to keep
himself like you said relevant
he's very fortunate conor mcgregor
graced him with his presence with his
life because otherwise like
he'd be nobody
yeah no that's absolutely true and you
can tell him and mcgregor have not hung
out for [__] the longest time and yet
he's still posting pictures of him in
connor as if they were like coming out
last week
i'm not liking that
i don't even [__] know you anymore
bro you're in do you know what i mean
like it's he's hiding under that like
the guy who like used to be in the band
do you know what i mean like it's
yeah
it's awkward man and brother that never
was i i look at him and i honestly like
when he's sort of
dissing me i'm like bro you're pathetic
like you you actually have a
career that's going up in smoke in front
of your very eyes
and
i know you're not making good money i
know you're not achieving anything
you're not you're
logan paul
would be the best thing that he could
ever [__] hope to happen
win or lose like it's the same as tommy
you've been getting them a couple of
million again like grab this
buy sell a house bro because the next
two million ain't going to be there for
a while especially after logan
embarrasses him which i believe would
happen in a ring yeah let's actually
talk about if they if they did want to
you know actually get into a fight and
dylan showed up uh logan like i said
skill wise the better boxer no doubt
about it the only thing and this is just
because of of
when logan feels threatened i i i want
to see that evolution of when logan
feels threatened how does he fight right
ksi there was the power threat
with floyd there was the skill threat
and the cardio threat and
he was in a negative state of mind in
both of those fights i think uh by
comparison to where if he fights dylan
he needs to be the predator not the prey
he needs to look at dylan like dinner
and go and [__] get on him straight
away and start
smashing that jab in his face and
actually use the gifts that we we see
him because he ain't
logan as good as he is like and this is
why i sort of suggested the winner of
mcbroom versus gabe i'm not
saying mcbroom or gabe will beat logan
but
logan has picked fights that were
obviously not the best for him in i mean
he hasn't won one so right you you you
the part of the jake thing that is he's
made statements and he's grown as a
fighter and i think logan has grown but
he needs to get in there with someone
who he knows he should be and he needs
to be the alpha
mentally
we haven't seen
like if we're talking mentality we
haven't seen logan in the same mentality
like he'll faint it he'll say you know
how confident he is and
in the floyd fight i think he found a
little bit of that toward the end he was
like hey i'm still here like you
couldn't get rid of me but we haven't
really seen that confident level or a
confidence level since gsi won in the
first couple of rounds in that fight and
you were right there in person to see it
right and good shout bro yeah i remember
though
because this was the thing is i was sort
of thinking okay ksi's done with the
experience he looked good against joe
weller and those first two rounds logan
when he was popping that job and jj's
head was going back i was like [__]
hell this kid is good and then yeah but
the mentality if
and the gas tank ultimately it failed
him and it was jj who had the more
aggressive nature and that's obviously
what carried him through the both of
those fights but
he needs to he needs to get that he
needs to go in there and go i'm going to
rip this [__] guy's head off and he
and he and the the thing about dylan or
whoever he chooses is he needs to get in
there soon because
logan seems to take
long periods between boxing and he he
clearly as people have commented on in
the podcast loves the good life you know
he's he look i mean i don't know what he
has going on he looked like he was on
hard drugs i was like oh man this guy is
doing it different out in london nah
fair play everybody wants to have a good
time i'm not you know do what you want
to do but i was like oh he's living it
up no and i mean like i genuinely think
that that is just logan on like a boozy
night to be honest but like i look like
logan and i'm like if i had your talent
and i had your money i'd of a gym built
on the side of my house i'd have the
[__] black belts turning up teaching
me kickboxing jiu-jitsu wrestling i'd be
because he has all of the skills to be
an mma fight i wrote to do whatever he a
boxer or do whatever he wants like i
think he may be the most naturally
talented of all of these guys
but i said this too i saw it on someone
put a little uh
tweet up they were like who's got the
most potential for boxing and it was
like
it's easily logan and that's kind of
what i was thinking about the the
mcbroom gabe fight is if one of them
looks really good and the next fight and
proves that they're a legit test i know
logan feels like he's above sort of that
youtube standard now from fighting
mayweather but
if you haven't won a fight you're not
above anything you know you've got to
get a win
yeah i think you've got to get some wins
under your belt just like jake did and
especially if mcbroom wins
there's a fight where
why not you know what i mean unless ksi
takes it but let's talk about um ksi is
coming back and um
allegedly it's alex wasabi um i don't
really see who else it could be at this
point um how are we feeling just
generally about the return right now
i am
very hopeful um just based off who he's
with over at shoot fighters in london
i'm sure you know a couple guys in that
gym i'm sure you've had some
conversations i think you've talked to
mvp before
actually but i've obviously i've watched
the guy and he's still here
you know we see sort of anderson silva
like [__] i was gonna say the second
coming man the second coming pieces he
is fun to watch but
they don't all look like him but one
thing i do know as leon
has seen
him and leon gave an interview and he
said the style's different so
what we've been hearing from jj is that
he's going to come out differently i
think a lot of people have been
skeptical of that but leon's confirmed
it the style is different
yeah it's what is it we don't know but
what we do know is jj's style against
phase um sensei was
bite down on the gum shield guy on the
inside and work the body and dirty box
you in the corner and up against the
ropes and that and just keep that
pressure on so i can only assume this is
a bit more of a traditional
you know use the jab
bit more like the joella thing i did see
watching him in the joe weller lead up
and even a little bit after him just
kind of goofing off a lot of a lower
hand style a lot more loose flowy
straight punches not a lot of overhands
and i think if we can get to simplify
the big things like the big things
everybody wants to talk about oh his
hands high everything if we can just
simplify things where is he comfortable
if his hands are a little lower listen
i'm not a big proponent of it with guys
that are new because
you leave yourself open to getting hit
with big shots if you're not quick and
when your gas tank is not as great
your hands aren't going to be able to
move up and down as quickly as you think
they are but
if he's comfortable and he's throwing
straight punches i think that is where
jj is going to have to be
if he's going to continue this right i'm
not overlooking alex but if this is
going to be something he continues to do
and let's say he goes in and gets a
victory if it is alex
you can't rely on the fact that you're a
dog you can't just rely on it right it's
a great thing to have
but technique has to be there so the
in the past he's done like one or two
rounds when yeah [__] this like
that's the neck out all right here we go
derek vidal's died and
apparently after that second round he
just goes to vidal do you want to
[__] win this fight or not
you know i mean like
you know what we need to do so get into
him get fight him [__] this [__] fight
him you know
but that yeah it should be last resort
and um
and the thing with alex
is the reason i knew alex was going to
beat deji is because the kid is an
athlete
and obviously i don't mean like
literally but like he is so fit and you
could see on those training videos you
were like you can't fake that you know
and we don't know how much he's grown
because i thought he showed he showed
some ring iq he showed he could jab and
move he showed he could control the
fight um
so
and this is the same kid who basically
got slapped up by uh fousey in the first
ever fight he had but he showed that
like there's there's more to him than
what we originally thought and
i think the the part of the issue here
is is um
it's your first fight back
you're loading all of the pressure on
yourself
yeah and
the the thing about jj is there's nobody
better at handling crowds because the
kid performs in front of the biggest
crowds in the uk all the time just did
like a show with 80k or something right
it's just insane so i have confidence in
him in handling the pressure
but when you've got that little fly
buzzing around that ring and you're sort
of if you you know a couple as you said
a couple of rounds go by you start
struggling frustration starts building
people all came here to see you knock
someone out we've seen even vidal riley
in his first uk fight felt that pressure
a little bit and this is a guy who's
wanted all that amateur
you start tensing up you start throwing
and snatching at it and not
playing your normal game basically and
that's where we might see him revert to
windmill it's coming out it'll come out
at some point whether he gets frustrated
with alex because he can't get him out
and i'm not saying that he can't but if
that happens or
just as the start of the fight goes and
that dog quote unquote dog comes out
right and he just has to calm it down
like he gets excited we saw we saw one
of the funniest things i've ever seen uh
ksi getting ready for the logan 2 fight
and he's in the corner and then he just
starts screaming
and fidel's like chill chill like he's
just you know sometimes it happens to
you you get so excited so i i do expect
that especially early from him but i
want to see him calm it down
while yes alex does show a decent amount
of footwork i've actually talked with
alex on my my podcast and you know he's
talking i think he came across really
well on that interview i watched that
yeah and that was another thing where i
was like okay he's winning this because
he's a realist i think if he plays that
way with jj it it could work well for
him that he's not
um
and trying to be too theatrical yeah
yeah
is because ksi is gonna gonna bring a
little bit of that right he's a showman
at the end of the day he's gonna bring
that energy he's gonna do something i
will never forget by the way
i was thinking about this the other day
ksi versus logan won the press
conference
and yeah when jj comes out puts that
blonde wig on and goes to work and just
starts roasting logan this is after
logan had just just been off the back of
the obviously the japan video yeah it it
was one of the most like cauldron like
atmospheres like he can create
a crowd mentality where he just gets the
entire room chanting use oh he's dick he
had the room shaking for sure
it was i was just sitting there like
what the [__] is going on yelling and
logan's like frozen well logan wasn't
happy with me obviously this was four
and a half years ago now yeah and
understandably so because i let him i
left him how i don't have to try there
but um
i was uh
i i just remember being like there was
no stopping jj when he's in that mine
state and he's got the crowd behind him
and his star is even bigger now he is
even more confident now
i i think that's one of the things to to
alex is
he's gonna mentally if he has any chance
in this fight he has to make himself
accept what's coming
make peace with it and go i'm going to
be i'm going to be the [__] a little
bit here in in some of the but i've got
to keep my state of mind calm
and i've got to enjoy the process and go
with it and not and not let it swallow
me and accept what this is going to be
and he had a great test run for it right
maybe not on the same level but he's
already been to london he's already
handled the heckling he's already been
in front of you know that crowd telling
him you know who are you who are you
know that whole thing he's done it
didn't he call him big deji or something
like that
on my online
i have to say right
small w there i was like i'm mad it's
quite funny though
if you were gonna
if not i you know far better from me to
start giving no tips but like i do feel
like this kid needs it because jj is
going to bring the heat so if you've got
a few little look i already took one of
you out like whatever this is just
like play with that because
you're going to need everything bro
watching him get riled up at alex just
beating deji and then calling him big
deji it does show that there's a lot of
fire there right the ksi was old school
as well the the videos back and forth
between these two they're years old like
so like he's done like laughing at alex
wassabi compilations at this point so
like
the bottom line in my opinion is
ksi is going to have to show
not us not even alex but himself
that he can remain in a composed state
not freak out not go with the windmills
not get over excited because there is a
path to victory for alex how small it is
you know i'll let you guys be the judge
but there is a path to victory and it
mostly relies on the fact that ksi does
something to give openings to alex
we've talked a bit about state of mind
about like that fight-or-flight
mentality of fighters and youtube guys
trying to become fighters and that's why
jake and ksi make such a dream matchup
for us because we know when the when
things get tough they both start trying
to kill you not trying to defend
themself whereas logan
more defensive minded so
with jj if if alex can can create that
pressure
on him to finish him and make the
narrative when you're going to finish me
jj when you're going to finish me i'm
still here and i remember watching
justin poirier in the fight against uh
conor mcgregor the second one and you
could see at the end of the first round
when dustin started gaining confidence
he's ah i got you i got you and you
could see connor like why are you still
here was a complete witch
and and
and then if you get j.j into that
reckless frame of mind and you're alex
wassabi you're on your bike you're
probably carrying less weight than him
so you're pumping the job running around
just trying to get out um out of each
round with with those 10 points
that's the kind of environment he has to
create in order to survive jj's power
yeah let's make no mistake about it this
is ksi's fight to win right this is a
hundred percent not only i don't want to
say set up but not only
does he have almost all of the
advantages that he needs size
experience even i would say ability
but there are there is a path to victory
and you have to not only take alex
wasabi seriously but you have to show
more than you've shown right not just
for this fight but for the future we've
never seen ksi knock someone out called
and assuming this is
turnouts gloves no headguards um
it's going ksi needs a knockout and and
i say that because
if people are to
get
really invested in the jake versus ksi
fight
depending on what happens between tommy
and jake because that could change the
trajectory of how people view jake but i
think
we all agree a prime jake paul knocks
out alex wasabi the same way he knocked
out everybody else he got in the ring
with so i think that would go a long way
for jj and also it would give him a
massive confidence boost of i've been in
there i've knocked him out i've got a
new style i'm knocking people out now
you know and um i think that's what we
need from him okay bro we'll do some uh
quote-unquote real boxing uh yeah let's
talk about it man that's some mma
yeah
we we've seen the press conference um
anthony joshua versus alexander yusick
ii
what did you make of it i feel like if
you're aj right now
this guy took pretty much everything
from
and i know he tries to keep an even kill
and now he's with robert garcia and
they've changed some things up that's
what i like
what i don't like is him sounding like a
self-help book at the press conference
and talking about brownies and and
here's my dietitian plan like i don't
understand this
and it's not to say that he's not going
to show up and have you know a
completely new like just go after age or
go after usyk and eat him up like to the
body eat him alive but these pressers
they don't make me confident in aj men
i think eddie hearn is very lucky that
he is selling this fight on ability and
what happened in the first fight then
personality you basically had eddie
going and then you did this uh aj and
then that happened didn't didn't didn't
you aj didn't you and then it just like
yeah i mean stay humble yo say humble
stay hungry like it's
you know
and then you've got us on the other side
is just you know he's a little playful
but he looks like a killer over here
he's a [__] machine and then you've
got like uh it felt like a much more of
a pr exercise for saudi arabia or the
kingdom uh
than it was for any of us to get
interested in this fight whatsoever it's
like
and i i think the pressure
is on aj so much this time
this is this is do or die it is it's
kill or be killed actually in in the
ring especially i think you have to be
ready to unload the clip and and
and hope you've got him out of there
afterwards
yeah i mean listen aj we we walked we
all the way back to the klitschko fight
we know that aj's had some gas tank
issues you know uh
klitschko predicted it put it on the usb
stick we remember he's like i got the
prediction right here and he basically
said the prediction was aj was going to
try to come after him gas out he's going
to knock him out didn't happen that way
close and we haven't seen really aj go
to that next we've seen that aj we've
seen a little bit of a maybe a
regression when it came to the
motivation for the andy ruiz fight and
then re-motivated and stayed behind his
jab right but we haven't seen
is he gonna go take someone's heart
again has he gone out there and wanted
to go in and you know
meet that challenge by going all right
we're here now it's man mono imano i'm
gonna take your heart he hasn't done
that since the the klitschko fight to me
it's it's ironic because it's kind of
the opposite of what we've just been
saying about ksi in a way of like he
mentally we need the killer back we
don't we don't want him controlled we
don't want him we we want him controlled
to know when to pull the trigger but
once you pull the trigger you gotta go
absolute base mode on him like um yeah
you can't allow yousek to survive
because if he survives that barrage and
you've unloaded the clip as aj does
you're a sitting [__] duck then and
yusuke will finish him
yeah
it won't be like klitschko where
klitschko is 42 years old and he also
needs four rounds to get his breath back
after dropping you they they will this
guy was doing i think they said he was
doing four minute rounds with uh like 30
seconds rest in between
and when i watch the aj fight back you
know i'll give credit aj hung in there
with him like in terms of pace of fight
like that was he was so fit
but even still
because he played his game and and the
instructions were so shocking stay
behind the job aj stay behind the job
like what do you think this knockout's
going to fall into his lap you've got to
go after him at some point absolutely
there was no
it was never
they never forced the issue the way he
did with pulev and all these other
fighters but like you said it's a risk
for sure but what do you have to lose
now your belts aren't there you have to
go in and
rip to the body of usyk rip him to the
body the smaller man in there coming up
from cruiser
the body is a bit of a weakness if you
have one on usyk
rip him and it's not as easy as just me
saying hey go rip his body obviously
usyk's slick obviously he's got a nice
jab he can like you said change levels
move off the center line you're not
going to catch him still he's not going
to stand in front of his his feet in
terms of closing the distance i think
he's the best heavyweight in the world
especially because
when he was stepping in with that uh
backhand
aj was just getting shook like where the
[__] did that come from because he's in
and out so beautifully and he faints aj
and it's he he'll freeze you right he
faint in between your timing and he
freezes you yeah and it's hard to
predict because he's constantly touching
you as well
their style is
it's not as much um sharp shooting the
way aj is sort of trying to get you like
like the terminator like yusik's always
touching you he's always touching you
and it almost becomes like a
a habit that you can't allow him to get
into you when he gets that near you like
you say blast him to the body and be
like don't [__] come near me prick
you know seriously he's gonna have to
like it's gonna have to be aj taking
precedence here he's gonna have to go on
the front foot and meet him and you
might even have to try to chase us down
a bit here because he is slick and he's
not going to stay in front of you
there's been a lot of talk about the
chin of aj because of those wobbles that
we've seen him have
and i'm not suggesting that he's got a
bad chin
but if he does or if it's questionable
to the degree that some people have said
it is we'll find out because for this
game plan
it surely means with the new coach
they've got um they've got that
yeah
that that style that he's employing is
going to have to be take a punch to give
a couple or
and he's when you're marching someone
down you need to have that like ability
to do that so if there's any
issues with aj's chin
this is the fight we'll see him out
called like this
it'll it'll either work and he wins by
knockout or he will be out called in my
opinion i don't see any middle ground
here yeah i think we're in for a [__]
treat here because
knowing someone has to pull the trigger
it makes it exciting because we're all
going to be sitting there going when is
he going to do it when is he going to do
it and what and what i like about you is
he's a bag of tricks as well i wouldn't
be surprised if yusik runs out in that
first round and tries to beat him to the
punch concrete yeah because yusik has a
thing in his head that aj doesn't where
user kinda knows
i can push the pace of this fight and no
my recovery will come back before yours
does
genetically he's just got that and
when i watched um the 12 rounds back
that was one of the most that that is
the fittest i've ever seen a heavyweight
at the elite level like
the amount of [__]
faints and the footwork and the constant
throwing the jab out there the the the
energy that he expelled in that like no
wonder aj was drowning at the end
because there's just no way to keep up
with that
there was no there was no drop off in
his explosion when he showed it right he
was playing the pity pat pitty pat and
then he would fire that left hand down
the pipe and it was the same in round
one the commentators are saying early on
you'll see the speed of you sick but
eventually the speed will go and that's
when aj will take over
and like
it was round 10 and he's just still
[__] [__] the [__] floor me it
was amazing
one fighter who i want to end on is uh
nate diaz um we've spoken about the way
ufc treat their fighters this guy's been
stuck in limbo uh clearly wanting to go
and fight jake paul and make a [__] ton
of money
oh he's not hiding that anymore
yeah and i mean why bother because
that's clearly why the ufc have got
their foot on nate diaz's neck and not
allowing him to make a living he
he obviously didn't do the kamza
fight
which i think given nate's stage of his
career is just such a like
it's not the best way to treat a guy
who's bled for you for so many years at
this point you've got an up-and-coming
fighter who's trying to fight for a
title nate is more of a veteran legend
at this point
and you're saying
but then
nate literally was the fight that got
the title shot done for um leon edwards
yeah that's the one sorry for leon
edwards um and like he rocked leon right
at the end of that and leon was like one
of the the sharpshooters of that
division
and and then afterwards because you had
dana talking up nate diaz when it suited
him and now now dana's going well you
know nate's only won one fight in the
last five years so maybe a jake paul
fight does make sense and i'm like
the guy was good enough for you to you
guys this guy's bled for your company
and been one of the one of the backbones
to build a company like the ufc without
innate diaz selling against conor
mcgregor like
you you you might not get the big sale
that you got like this don't get four
you don't get 4.2 bill without this yeah
you know connor needed a a
a dance partner so for for dana i talked
down on nate d i was like that and i'm
not even a nate diaz fan particularly
but the lack of respect from dana i
thought was a bit disappointing i
thought myself like i get if you've had
some personal beef
but
you you're you're a man who's made 400
500 million or whatever it is at this
stage off of these fighters and people
like nate diaz massively contributed to
that and for you to just sort of spit on
his record after he's been good enough
for you for all these years i thought
that's
it's distasteful really
yeah well listen dana is the king of
calling his current champion the
greatest ever right when you're fighting
for him you're the greatest ever when
you leave him
tyrone woodley being the best example of
that probably yeah huddly been asking
like we've seen it and to be fair you
know dana does have points you know nate
is not what nate maybe was at a certain
point right it's not necessarily a bad
thing to say nate is not shouldn't be
fighting guys like hamza chimaya which
they tried to put him in there
he was good enough to be the the the
basically number one
for leon he's good enough probably to be
the number one contender fight for hamza
chameleon nate is nate isn't fighting
bombs nate's fighting murderer's role
here like so when you say he hasn't got
a win all right i get that but who the
[__] he been in there with like mas
vidal during his absolute peak of his
career like you didn't give him one
gimme fight like this and you say the
way people like diego sanchez did you
hear that that was it a phone call or an
interview he gave where he broke down in
tears like they now you know i [__]
died for this [__] company basically and
um and people like randy couture um
a guy who without who i might not even
be an mma fan you know like watching his
fights when he fought tim sylvia this
guy was the guy and they built the ufc
off of him one of the main he fought
brock lesnar when the guy was 45 years
old and a natural 205 like
one of the toughest [__] ever
lived and
he was a classic case of someone who
went from
goat status to yesterday's news and just
a nobody now and because dana had a bit
of a
disappointment uh thing with him because
he wanted uh to get his money or
whatever and it's
yeah i think what they've done and nate
diaz is back out of order when
everything he's given for that company
they
you know i get you don't want to make
your competitors stronger but it's not
like he's going to go over any where can
he go he just wants to make some cash
with jake paul it ain't going to hurt
the ufc it ain't going to change
anything for the ufc why do you care
when your day in our white you've made
all this hundreds of millions and it's
bothering you that nate diaz might go
off and make 10 million with jake paul
like are you really that like bitter
either it's either that that nate is
like the only thing i can see like
logically would be the reason
is if they're planning a conor in nate
fight and they want to get that one and
then they're like okay
after that go do it because there's no
doubt about it that there's so much
money to be made with nate and connor
still but when you start saying things
like well you should go fight jake paul
well why the [__] would anyone want to
then come back and go yeah let's watch
nate and connor but dana just [__] on
nate telling him yeah
yeah yeah yeah pivot now you've
you you've put him in the bargain bin
you can't say that jake's gonna he needs
to go fight jake and that's a skill for
skill level when conor's coming back and
then go maybe we'll put him in there
with conor because now you've without
saying it said that conor's a bargain
shopper now too it's been a good chat
wade i appreciate you coming on the pain
game brother
no i appreciate it like i said man this
is this has been we've been working on
this since i think 2020
uh when when you discovered little older
weight concepts back in the day hey i i
i discovered you like way before most
people
yeah it was you know it was you and it
was sensei that that you know you
reached out really early and i like i
said man it's it's a blessing to be here
because
believe it or not five years ago i was
sitting in a bedroom something like this
uh watching your videos man i was
watching
when uh you did the podcast on michael
bisming i was back then i was watching
that stuff and i was like man this guy
i want to do that you know so
anybody and i know you get comments and
stuff and people i think people forget
who the [__] you really are in this
scene
people let me just remind you there like
i said when i came on here there's no
wade concept without true jordy
you're likeable i'm i'm a i'm an [__]
but um no man i appreciate it and look
mate at the end of the day with or
without without uh inspiration um
i rate everything you do and it's always
nice when someone you enjoy
their videos also likes your videos so
tip of the cap from both ends mate
you're a legend and i
i'm pretty sure we'll work with each
other at some point
i think you're right about that
[Laughter]
so yeah um this has been the first
episode um between me and wade but i'm
pretty sure we're gonna do more if you
want more do let us know in the comments
and we can make this a fairly regular
thing hopefully i'd love to have weighed
on plenty more and to catch up on
the combat sports chat don't forget to
check out the weird concept youtube
channel i'll put the link in the
description below hit that like button
subscribe thanks for watching and we'll
see you later